on vous parle maintenant et comme à
chaque année depuis presqu'une dizaine
d'années en fait ici à l'émission de la
lecture en cadeau
grâce à ce programme depuis quinze ans
des milliers d'enfants du quartier
défavorisé reçoivent un livre tout neufs
cette année sur les 38 1500 livres
amassés distribué plus de la moitié sont
allés aux enfants de moins de 6 ans anne
louise despatie je suis un chat je ne
sais pas volé et je sais nager
chaque année la comédienne marie turgeon
est au rendez vous j'abandonne
je n'arrivais plus jamais avant lui elle
vient faire la lecture un cadeau qu'elle
offre aux enfants parce que c'est un
chat
qu'est ce que c'est elles l'avouent elle
a un faible pour les plus petits comme
ceux de la maternelle
aujourd'hui je peux donner pâques sur
l'émerveillement lire c'est le fun c'est
plonger
promue tête première dans l'imaginaire
c'est ça que je communiquais sait lire
toi nous des gens l'ont courage de pour
lire et pourront temps pour recevoir des
histoires ces jours ci la fondation pour
l'alphabétisation distribuer 38500
livres neufs depuis 15 ans elle offre en
mai les livres qui ont été achetés par
des milliers de donateurs avant noël
tu peux regarder c'est d'abandonner une
motion la fondation souhaiterait pouvoir
répondre à toutes les demandes provenant
des écoles et des garderies en milieux
défavorisés
mais il en faudrait pour cent mille
enfants ont fait l'hypothèse donc on ne
croit pas se tromper que dans plusieurs
de ces familles là il y a peu ou pas de
livre et que les parents peuvent
également être eux mêmes de faibles
lecteurs ont fait le pari qu'ont rejoint
un maximum d'enfants qui en ont besoin
et tant mieux pour les autres c'est
toujours un beau cadeau un livre la
moitié des livres offerts sont destinés
à des enfants qui ne savent pas encore
lire
on espère ainsi que la découverte de
l'objet qui est le livre puissent
allumer le désir de lire plus tard je
dirais mâchonner son livre à six mois et
peut-être une garantie d'en dévoiler le
contenu à 14 ans j'ai fait m
tilly c'est environ 10% des enfants
retournent la faveur à l'ordonnateur en
postant la carte pré adressé qui peut
être ajouté aux livres faire ici anne
louise despatie radio canada longueuil